[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you on Thursday 5th
of January Happy New Year
I'm Cindy Yu The Spectators assistant
editor
coming up on the show
is the Democratic party stuck with Biden
for the next election it's been rumored
that he may well run again even though
he's already 80 years old what would six
more years of Biden look like I'm joined
by Freddie gray and Jeff Cohen
Douglas Murray is also on the show this
week we'll be talking about British
politicians weakness for Khan kicking
and the latest review stuck in the
Whitehall pipeline all about how to fix
prevent the anti-extremism strategy that
well has had mixed success
number two politicians not known for
being exciting Inspire the country in
what will be a very difficult year while
they've both tried with New Year's
speeches this week our associate editor
Isabelle Hardman joins me on the show to
discuss
and as the war continues between Russia
and Ukraine my colleague Svetlana
morinets was finally able to return to
Ukraine and see her family for Christmas
how much has changed since she was last
there last year Svetlana joins me on the
show
years into the future could AI help us
fight Wars not just in Weaponry but
possibly in strategy or advice this is a
possibility opened up by the latest
breakthrough in artificial intelligence
the ability to lie and betray Mark
galiotti joins a shame
and finally what is it like to be an
Agony Aunt this week's issue looks at
the agony aunt's Victorian roots and to
discuss I'm joined by the telegraph's
agony Uncle Richard madley
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss an
episode
and you can subscribe to The Spectator
in our new year sale and get a whole
Year's worth of unparalleled comment
analysis for as little as 49 pounds to
subscribe today go to spectator.co.uk
forward slash sale
first up will there be six more years of
the Joe Biden Administration Paul
suggests that the majority of Democrats
don't actually want Biden as their party
nominee in 2024 and at the age of 82
will he even make it for another full
term for the cover piece this week our
Deputy editor Freddie gray looks at what
that presidency might look like and he
joins me now together with Jeff Cohen an
American political expert who has set up
the campaign don't run Joe
Freddie and Jeff welcome to spectator TV
now Freddie your piece of looking at the
prospect of six more years of Joe Biden
so is it the expectation that he will
run again in 2024. well that certainly
seems to be the talk uh in much at the
moment it certainly seems to be going
that way
um since Joe Biden was elected uh in
2020 won the election in 2020 uh there
has been this sort of will he won't be a
placeholder president uh question
looming over him
um and I'd say six months ago if you
spoke to some Democrats in Washington
they would say actually he may well move
aside but at that stage the presidency
was clearly going very badly
um among team Biden people uh they feel
the last few months have gone very well
they feel the midterms was uh an actual
success even though they lost the house
um they feel the inflation the inflation
is coming down and things are looking
better and Biden himself seems to be in
better spirits and apparently crucially
his wife Jill the first lady uh has come
round to the idea of a second term so
the word in Washington is that uh he he
may well soon announce that he's going
to run again but you have to bear in
mind as I say in the piece of the word
in Washington is almost always wrong
quite probably a lie but yeah
let's look at that track record then
because I think it's fair for me to say
that you're not super impressed by the
track record but even you managed to
find something that he has done while in
foreign policy for example in sustaining
this war in uh Ukraine supporting
Ukraine and trapping Russia in this
extended War he has a managed to turn
towards China so has he been all that
bad well if you look at Joe Budden's the
real collapse in Joe Biden's uh poll
ratings it was in his first year when he
withdrew from Afghanistan uh and there
was a sort of you know a loss of
criticism for that uh the political
classes were very upset by it and it was
sort of seemed to be an embarrassment
for America on the world stage but what
that has enabled him to do is remove
America from the sort of Quagmire of a
wit of a war that it was never going to
win
still terrible for Afghanistan that was
inevitable either way but he has
supported Ukraine there is a lot of uh
difference of opinion in America about
whether that's a good idea far more than
there is in Europe and Britain uh but he
appears to have won in the sense that
Ukraine is doing better than anyone
expected and so America by not being
militarily involved but by supporting uh
Ukraine and sending billions and
billions in military aid uh has been
seen to be winning and on a real
politique level that has worked because
it enables America to focus on its true
strategic rival which causes China so it
seems quite shrewd and at least this
particular front it is rude uh how much
Joe Biden is behind it is is a question
of some dispute yes that's a very fair
point um now Jeff you're on the left of
the American political divide but you
also think that Biden shouldn't rerun
you've recently set up the don't run Joe
campaign we can see a bit of your
campaign ad here Joe Biden running
undermines the Democratic party's
chances in 2024. there's no question
that we have a climate emergency it's a
question of willingness to do something
about it it's not the time for half
measures all Americans need Universal
Health Care Now there's no room to
compromise when our abortion rights are
on the line we can't afford to lose
don't run Joe don't run Joe don't run
Joe don't run Joe since your problem
with Biden that he isn't going far
enough on some of these left-wing issues
well my problem is he isn't a strong
leader he's out of step with the base of
the Democratic Party
nearly 60 percent of Democrats in recent
polls want a different candidate for
president in 2024.
the New York Times had a poll in July
that found more than 90 percent of
Democrats under 30 wanted a different
candidate
the base of the party wants profound
change because our country is facing
these crises
of climate
of democracy
of widening economic and racial
inequalities
and the Democratic party base wants real
change and it's our belief
that when Washington Democrats
deliver real change and make the lives
of working-class people anxious middle
class people fundamentally better
it undercuts what's a major threat in
our country which is the faux populism
the authoritarian right-wing populism of
a trump or a DeSantis so our main it's
not an issue of too much or too little
or too left or too right he's not a
strong leader and he's out of step with
the uh base of the democratic party now
we all rallied around him
to get rid of trump in 2020 and we all
rallied around Democrats to try to beat
back the you know extremist Republican
Party in the 2022 Congressional
elections but you know I'm with the
majority of Democrats when I say we need
a stronger presidential candidate in
2024. so Jeff Woody you say to those
Defenders of Biden who tot off the track
record that we've been mentioning for
example lower inflation high employment
foreign policy all of these things do
you not buy into that track record
I don't buy into it at all I I mean I
was thrilled by the original
uh covid Recovery Act that passed soon
after
uh Biden took power a lot of the other
initiatives have been totally watered
down what passes ultimately have been
very weak too little too late
um you know you talk about foreign
policy most Democrats want our military
spending cut
so we can have something that many
people in Europe have
which is Universal Health Care
you know our country spends 858 billion
it's record-breaking it's beyond bloated
858 billion US Dollars on the Pentagon
alone
and then we spend this is the coming
budget 21 billion to modernize
the U.S nuclear weapons and another 8
billion to do cleanups around U.S
nuclear weapon sites how much and that's
all in the department of energy how much
does the department of energy spend on
renewable energy or on Energy Efficiency
just a mere four billion so our
priorities are out of whack so no the
base of the democratic party wants these
priorities changed in a gradual way but
in a sustained way we aren't extremists
like the right Wingers who are tearing
up Capitol Hill this week and did on
January 6 2021 but we want serious
change that will undermine the fall
populace on the far right wing in our
country
well Freddie is there anyone like that
in the Democratic party who can deliver
what Jeff would like to see I think well
I can have a good answer in that
question but I think Jeff should after
me because as far as I can see there
doesn't really seem to be anybody Bernie
Sanders is of course uh the great
Tribune of the American left uh but I
very much doubt given all the doubts
about Biden's mental faculties and so on
um that they would replace him with
someone who's even older than Joe Biden
which would be Bernie Sanders and I
can't see another Democratic figure uh
people talk about Pete bootage but I
can't see that happening really uh there
are various Governors who generate some
excitement Gavin Newsom was talked about
a lot but he's not exactly well liked I
wouldn't have thought by the left of the
party either and he has actually said he
doesn't intend to challenge Joe Biden so
I'd like to know who Jeff thinks Jess
yeah Jess who is who is the person who
takes on Biden and wins in 2024.
well uh Freddie you made a point in your
article
you know that Biden looks like he's
lacking energies lost a step
he mumbles through speeches Bernie yes
is a year older than Biden even
but there's no one in years that has
questioned the energy of Bernie Sanders
now I don't expect Bernie to run again
but what we want is an open process
and in that open process we believe a
senator a congress member a mayor
someone's going to emerge that
represents the base of the party and I
don't agree with this idea that the
Democrats will be in chaos if they have
an Open Primary you'll remember in 2020
uh we began the presidential race
actually in the early debates in 2019
and there were so many Democratic
candidates
uh 20 of them that they had to debate
divide the televised debate into 10 on
one night and 10 the next night
um and yet
the party came together behind Biden
with the goal of defeating Trump after
20 candidates initially had sought the
presidency and we defeated Trump so I'm
one who wants an Open Primary do I know
now who the candidate will be that could
Galvanize the base of the party
Progressive activists racial Justice
activists I'm not sure uh I think Evan
Newsom would probably run it would be a
more difficult candidate for a DeSantis
or a trump to beat than Biden in 2024
it'll be status quo Joe Biden he'll have
to be defending his record we don't know
what the economy will be like so a lot
of Democrats we want a fresh start
we we fear the extremism of today's
Republican party but we're really
looking for a different standard Bearer
in November 2024.
[Music]
time but before we go I mean their
mentions Trump
do you think that he is going to be the
Republican nominee come the next
election I think it's far too soon to
Discount him I think a lot of
Republicans are eager to Discount him
because they see him as a weakness on
the ballot I think at the moment a very
interesting question is uh the justice
department are contemplating what to do
next uh whether to prosecute him on
various counts uh I think my theory is
that Joe Biden might be leaning on his
attorney general to say uh actually just
take this as slowly as possible because
As Long As Trump is in the National
conversation Joe Biden is seen as the
person who's beaten him before I take
what Jeff says I think he may well be
right but as far as Biden world is
concerned team Biden uh Biden is their
best bet for beating Trump again or
indeed uh winning if Trump runs someone
else close and splits the party apart
another point to remember is with the
Republican Party
they've never had the discipline of
freezing out uh to freeze out rebellious
populist candidates uh but Trump won if
you look at 2016 with Hillary Clinton
2020 with Joe Biden against Bernie
Sanders the party discipline The
Establishment party discipline to stop
him was quite impressive uh so I think
that's why the populist left will not
achieve what the populist right has done
in America yeah well thank you very much
Freddie and Jeff best of luck with your
campaign thank you for joining Space TV
and it's not just politicians in the US
that are uninspiring these days in this
week's magazine Douglas Murray lambasts
the culture of cankicking that British
politics has got itself in G we seem to
be report heavy and action light he
writes
so Douglas welcome back to spectator TV
um it seems to your column this week
that there are two problems you're
picking up on first is this culture of
just commissioning reports and they're
not really doing anything with them and
the second is what's happening with the
prevent strategy and how we can fix it
can we talk about that first one first
what is this culture that British
politics has got itself into where there
are just millions of reports but nothing
ever gets done
yes it's very strange I I say in my
column this week that it you could argue
it started with the coalition government
from 2010 to 2015. where the
conservative and liberal Democrats you
know had a lot they didn't agree on the
easiest way to not uh upset Nick Clegg
which was obviously in those years as we
know the absolute priority okay
um was was to kick things into
commissions inquiries reports uh
judicial overviews of things
um that way effective you didn't have to
decide anything remember for instance
that the energy problems that we have in
our country at the moment could actually
be remedied if it wasn't for the fact
that that coalition government just
endlessly sort of kicked things into the
long grass into reporting stages I mean
I wrote about this recently but you know
and I don't sound like I am picking on
him but well I am but Nick Clegg uh said
at the beginning of the Coalition you
know if if we did this new nuclear
reactor you know the the energy wouldn't
even come online until like 2022 2023 I
mean wow who could expect such a date to
ever arrive
um and actually it turns out you know we
could have done with decisions being
made on our energy at that point we
could have done with with with
questions like that in the National
interest not just being endlessly farmed
out to to commissions to reports to
inquiries and so on but somehow that
became the culture in Whitehall and even
when the conservatives got a majority
uh in 2015. that culture continued I
give the example in the column of the
Louise Casey review they looked into the
problems of integration in the UK I
admire Louise Casey very much I spoke to
her when she was doing that review
um and uh and a fine piece of work it is
but effectively the government said
thank you very much for delivering your
report and then and then shelved it
um nothing has happened so far as I can
see actually no no no deliverables to
use one of the ugly terms of government
about the Casey review and and you can
just see that on in case after case
we've We've Ended up with this sort of
government situation where something
happens and they say something must be
done and the something is a report that
will report at some point in the coming
years and then we don't have to listen
to it well to be fair I mean just going
back to Nick like maybe he already knew
that he wouldn't be in Westminster for
another 10 years
yes it seemed like an implausibly long
timeline for him
um and just just on these reports and do
you think the problem is that there's no
no eagle or moral political obligation
for
act on these reports once they're
commissioned and published as you say
they can just be shelved always said
that the reports themselves are often
not the right solution they don't
identify the problems well they
shouldn't be I mean you can't commission
a report and then say it's going to be
legally binding or a commission of
inquiries there's got to be legally
binding that that would be even more
impossible no I I think the problem is
just that there that there is no
political will to make decisions the
fact is is that when certain decisions
come across the prime minister's desk or
a Home secretary's desk they just have
to make the decision one way or the
other uh and as I say somehow we've got
stuck in this culture which is it's just
easier to farm it out it's easier to
kick a can along the road like why
um to get on to the the second part of
what you know what we're discussing the
prevent issue like why after the three
terrorist attacks in 2017 including the
London Bridge attack or London Bridge
one as it became known why did Theresa
may need to say enough is enough okay
sure like nobody loves seeing
schoolgirls blown up at a concert in
Manchester okay great enough is enough
what are you going to do about it prime
minister I'm going to appoint a
commissioner to look into the question
of extremism and then work on it for
years what happened I admire Sarah Khan
who was actually appointed as
commissioner but what happens is the
prime minister says all these people
have been killed in British cities in
London and Manchester and uh as a result
I'm going to commission an eminently
um you know suitable figure to look into
the problem of extremism what happens
that person takes years to for instance
at the beginning Define what extremism
might be
you know like when the London Bridge
attackers were slitting people's throats
on London Bridge in 2017 I mean I
imagine I don't want to speak for them
obviously or try to I imagine that
they've been surprised if they thought
that the response to this by government
would be a hermeneutical inquiry into
the nature of the term extremism
or a request to academics across the UK
to send in academic papers about areas
to do with extremism and radicalization
within the UK and then for that to go on
for years and years you know I mean it's
just not it's not a way to govern it's a
weak way to govern sure that's what
Theresa May demonstrated then just as
some of her predecessors had and that's
what I worry about with the the issue
which is sort of the culmination point I
tried to make in the column this week
yes well let's bring in that report
because there's another report stuck in
the White Hall pipes at the moment all
about extremism and terrorism tell us
about the shore cross report
yes uh well in the wake of the seven
seven bombings way back in 2005 uh the
Blair government instituted the prevent
strategy it was intended to uh address
issues of de-radicalization of
radicalization to try to identify people
who might be of interest it were just
before they come to the interest of the
security services or the police it was
highly controversial particularly within
the Muslim Community because a lot of
Muslim Community leaders said ah you're
targeting the Muslim Community and much
more and there has been a massive amount
of disinformation Pumped out about
prevent by primarily so-called leaders
in the Muslim Community who have
terrified the Muslim Indians what this
actually means
um the prevent strategy has metastasized
over the years again rather like Sarah
Khan report you get this thing of sort
of new
um well it's unfair just to look into
the people who are doing suicide
bombings why don't we look into other
types of extremism as well and I give an
example in the article that by now now
prevent actually and you've probably got
the quote in front of you uh Cindy
actually I mean it's worth reading out
what that definition if I can ask you if
I haven't got in front of me one of the
difference definitions of extremism of
prevent of cultural nationalism as the
ideology which is a belief that Western
culture is under threat from Mass
migration into Europe and from a lack of
integration by certain ethnic and
cultural groups and that is one of the
ideologies that they are attacking us
problematic so so so so prevent now or
in recent years has both covered as it
were the victim of terrorism and the
terrorists in the same smog Board of
allegations if if you're the per if
you're the young man who left a bomb on
the Underground trailer Parsons Green a
few years ago an illegal migrant who
shouldn't have been in the UK and made a
bomb and left it on a train if you're
that then you're a subject of interest
to prevent but also if say you were one
of the people on that train at Parsons
Green that morning who thought hey I'm
not that cool about people just walking
into my country making bombs and leaving
them on my underground train in the
morning well you're also a potential
subject of interest to prevent and that
that has been the problem of prevent the
metastasizing of it so the Boris Johnson
government remember him a commissioned a
review in to prevent perfectly suitable
to do it William shawcross the former
head of the charity commission a very
distinguished author and public servant
who was asked to do the review it was
delivered last summer when a pretty
Patel was Home Secretary remember her
you know this is how long ago we're
talking about in all these processes the
reports continue the inquiries continue
but Prime Ministers and home secretaries
come and go
um it was delivered last summer and it
is meant to be released fairly soon but
there's just been this blockage in the
system because the system is busily
debating the report that the system had
asked for and we're no closer to
addressing any of the questions though
than we were when Boris Johnson first
commissioned Shaw cross Douglas I wonder
if you've seen this reporting that I saw
about why there's a holder which is that
uh the home office has advised some
redactions of names of groups and
individuals uh in through in this report
and the reporting seemed to be that Sue
Ella Braverman a Home Secretary is
taking those reactions whereas Michael
Gove is pushing back and saying that we
need these names out there I don't think
that is how accurate that is to what is
happening behind the scenes but it seems
bizarre that Braverman who is isn't she
meant to be a bit of a bulldog in
defense of British values and very
difficult on terrorism
if if the reporting is true it's very
disappointing about the homer secretary
very disappointing indeed
um yes the report has been in the system
so long now that there has been
significant briefing of the reporters so
we all know what it says yes I mean it's
been leaked to every paper from the
telegraph to the guardian in in segments
uh by by obviously officials in the home
office
um uh many of whom will be will be
worried about the the prevent review
because they'll be worried about the end
of the boondoggle of of massive spigots
of public spending that reassure them
that they can spend their days sitting
at a desk chewing a pen pretending to
worry about what definition of extremism
we should use in the UK and so on but
anyway there's been lots of leaks one of
the leaks as you say is there is this
this hold up and it would be very very
disturbing if it was the case that the
Home Secretary or anyone else in
government was worried genuinely worried
about the naming of individuals in their
this report and it comes back to the
source of the problem what what the hell
is the point of commissioning work
looking into serious problems when in
the end of the process and at the end of
the process
officials are worried about upsetting
the feelings of extremists actual
extremists islamists in the UK what the
hell is the point of all of these
reports where even when you get to the
point in question you end up with
officials saying well we can't upset the
islamists can we well the awful thing
that would be um
Douglas Murray thank you for joining
spectator TV
great pleasure as always
optimistic
set out their respective New Year's
resolutions for the country this week
I had a more inspiring vision I'm joined
by our associate editor Isabelle Hardman
Isabelle welcome to spectator TV and now
let's go through Rishi sunax vision for
the party in the country first what did
you make of her speech so of the two
speeches this was definitely uh the less
interesting one and that's partly
because he's the guy in Power he's
actually gotta you know take to take
decisions and make promises that he has
some chance of of keeping but In
fairness to the Prime Minister a number
of the pledges he made this week are
going to be really difficult for him to
meet and he listed his five immediate
priorities the priorities of the people
as he called them they were halving
inflation this year growing the economy
national debt falling NHS waiting lists
will fall and new laws to stop small
boats
um now some of those things may well
happen regardless of what Rishi seen act
does such as halving inflation others
are pretty difficult uh to see how
they'd actually
um be accomplished so are NHS waiting
lists really going to be falling this
year when forecasts that will leap to
The Spectators Kate Andrews uh suggested
they're going to get much higher before
they start falling and they may well be
still at a record high at the next
election so will patients will people
generally feel as though the NHS is in a
better place probably not uh new laws to
stop small boats so is he just promising
to pass a law because you know I mean he
can actually do that given he's in
government
stopping the small boats is a little bit
more difficult and perhaps that's an
admission that
no one has really worked out how to do
that yet
and I'm surprised to hear that Kirsten's
speech actually managed to be more
interesting than that considering Keith
Summers you know always mocked for being
quite boring so what does he have to say
yeah I think we're in a sort of low bar
situation here and um
kirst armor does now feel that some of
the insults that were leveled at him by
the Tories early on he was boring and so
on are actually now compliments um
indeed when Rishi sunak took over as
prime minister one of the buzzwords of
his team was be boring
um and that was something that you know
Boris Johnson was always saying a sort
of Kirsten was failings whereas we've
had the the psychodrama of the
conservatives particularly over the past
year boring looks pretty appealing in
comparison
being in opposition does give you the
luxury of being able to talk about
things in a slightly more utopian
hopeful way kirstan was very keen to not
be a boring Winger because that that
really is unappealing and so he did try
to be optimistic and forward-looking
about what labor was going to do for the
country and the thing that I found the
most interesting uh was his Take Back
Control slogan that he's decided to
unashamedly steal from vote leave it
allowed him to talk about how he
campaigned to remain in 2016 but
understood the concerns of many of the
lead voters who he spoke to it also
allows him to use a hugely popular and
successful political slogan um rather
than having to come up with another one
himself which he hasn't
um but it also
gives him the opportunity to do
something that he hasn't done up to this
point which is suggests that labor might
be aiming to be in power for a while so
he talked about a decade of national
renewal so that's two terms in
government up to this point a lot of
senior labor people who I'd been talking
to and indeed a number of conservatives
had felt that the pitch from kirst armor
really was I'm going to turn up and
repair some of the damage make things go
better not a sort of long-term vision
for changing the balance of power in
this country for changing the way
government and the private sector works
for changing the state of our public
services so they function for you know a
modern society as opposed to just trying
to fix the gaping holes we got much more
of that list of reforms that amounted to
a vision today to the extent that I
suspect the complaint from now on will
actually be will where are the retail
offers from labor rather than where's
the big overarching Vision I think we've
now got to the stage where we know what
kirst
vision is whether or not it's exciting
I'm not sure
um but so but in terms of concrete
policies I think that's the move he now
needs to make and you know he's
definitely got the time to do that
this thing is about and as you say the
bar does seem quite low in terms of how
exciting either of the options are to
vote us next election thank you so much
for joining spectator TV
almost a year ago Russia invaded Ukraine
at that point my colleague Svetlana
morinets happened to be holidaying in
Europe and her family back in Ukraine
urged her to go seek refuge in the UK
instead of returning home she later
joined the spectator on our internship
scheme and now writes a weekly Ukrainian
Focus newsletter
this Christmas she has returned home to
Western Ukraine seeing her family for
the first time since war broke out what
is it like to spend this time of year in
a war zone she joins me now
Svetlana thank you for joining spectator
TV and it's great to have you especially
because you've only got a few hours of
electricity a day tell us what has it
been like to be reunited with your
family over the Christmas period and to
see your village again
sure I'm extremely happy happy because
it has been almost one year since I saw
them last time if you share a lot of
time together because when we don't have
electricity all what we do is just to
sit together and talk so
somehow it is even nice you know yeah
absolutely and when the war broke out
you happened to be traveling in Europe
and so you you came to the UK instead of
returning home but your family have been
there throughout the course of the war
what has life been like for them or you
know now you're seeing it and you're
living it you know would it work to just
can you just paint a picture of what
daily practical life looks like right
now
I'll say my family is very lucky because
I believe not on the eastern Ukraine we
live more or less on the central western
Ukraine
and here this the situation is more calm
but anyway we have air warnings every
day almost every day and sometimes you
can hear the explosions
and the most what the fact it does is
that there is no electricity and when
there is no clear State means there is
no water so
we use a lot of candles flashlights
we
wash ourselves with
balls of water we can't take normal
showers but I think it is a small price
to pay if to compare what
ukrainians pay how they live on the east
of Ukraine
and how our soldiers are bravely
fighting so uh here people that they
know in my town everybody understands
why it is happening and they're just
trying to get used to it
so yes yes it's it's heavy and the local
government are broke they don't spend
any budget for repairing the roads or
infrastructure anything at least here
and as far as I know they say that
everything goes for the Army all the
money but despite all this it's morale
still quite High I mean is it even
possible to have a Christmas as you have
done with Russian missiles flying
overhead
yes the morale is very strong and for
example New Year night Russia launched
some dozens of missiles to greet Ukraine
with New Year
and everybody was saying just here with
the [ __ ]
you know
because
people
Russians try to break the morale or a
spirit but it is
hopeless for them it's not gonna work
and I would
in the year and night we actually had
electricity and we could watch the
landscape on TV uh live
um given his speech
and it was very touching and everybody
was crying because you know every year
our ex-presidents were saying it was a
heavy year it was a heavy year but this
time he even didn't need to pronounce
those words
and in his speech he was saying that
this year will be the year of Ukraine's
Victory and every Ukrainian believes in
that yeah I mean I I think it's
incredible in your letter from Ukraine
you mentioned these letters to Santa
Claus you said Nicholas that
um have been published and some of the
requests I mean can you tell us about
that
yes you know uh usually in countries
that are in peace kids ask for toys
but here in Ukraine they ask for their
fathers their brothers to come back from
war alive and in a good health and also
they ask for putting to die
it's a common Vision Ukraine
yeah it'll be stuff like I wish for
Grandpa Vaso to return from the war
alive and well and for Putin to die in
the next sentence so I mean obviously
they can't hide from it you know they
can't hide from this wall it's very part
of their lives and you see that in your
brother's life as well and I think it
was his birthday on New Year's Eve as
well so he has yes he was he turned
eight and Years Eve and yes it is
impossible to hide because when when he
was going up his holidays but when he
was visiting school when there were air
warnings they need to stay in the bomb
shelter so you need to explain to the
kids why we are staying in the bomb
shelter and also
it was heartbreaking when I arrived to
Poland for taking the train to Ukraine
and my brother called me and asked if
the Krakow is being bombed too and how
do you explain to a kid why
this part of the land is being bombed
and another note and why is it fair or
so yes it is hard but and also the war
is constantly on TV how it is and says
swords so he sees that so he realized
that he's he's practically a kid of War
because he was born in 2014 when
everything started with when Crimea was
invaded and the war Indian bus broke out
so yeah he knows about it but I'm very
thankful that he knows about it not
directly that
I mean that the bombs were not falling
near our house you know
or he didn't see tanks on the our
streets so I still think that we are
very very lucky and it is only because
of our soldiers who are fighting there
on the front line well I hope you have a
safe journey back thank you so much for
calling in from near live so Atlanta
and you can subscribe to The Spectator
in our new year sale and get a whole
Year's worth of unparalleled comment and
Analysis for as little as 49 pounds to
subscribe today go to spectator.co.uk
forward slash sale
years into the future could Wars be
prevented by artificial intelligence the
technology has made Leaps and Bounds in
recent years cracking the ability to
paint pictures write stories and even as
Mark galliotti writes in this week's
spectator to lie and betray winning in
the game diplomacy against human players
for the first time last month
Mark is an expert on security and Russia
and he takes a look at what this means
for ai's ability to help in real life
diplomacy in the issue this week he
joins me now
Mark welcome to spectator TV now to
start with I wonder if you can just
explain the game diplomacy which is
known as Herring Kissinger's favorite
game what is it
actually it's a board game set in a
period leading up to the Great War and
the characters are you know the players
are all representing one of the great
Powers at the time and the interesting
thing about this is mechanically it's
incredibly simple there's no chance you
you move your armors and it's all just
simply a question of whether you have
preponderance where the real skill in
diplomacy comes in and this is where why
up to now it's not been something that
computers can really handle is the
basically the interaction between the
players negotiations
Bluffs and quite frankly formula answers
and then cheating and breaking them at
the most opportune moment and this is
why it's so important when you actually
have computers now computers have been
for a long time incredibly good at
entirely logical games such as chess or
go
where you know it can actually just
simply work out all the different
permutations and that's fine this the
point is you've actually got to be able
to talk to people you've got to be able
to understand what they're saying you've
got to be able to communicate what you
want and above all you have to try and
get your head around their intent and
these are the kind of soft skills that
up to now computers haven't really been
able to demonstrate any particular
Affinity at until we have artificial
intelligence incredible and and your
piece is all about how artificial
intelligence can be used in real
diplomacy and in international relations
in general I wonder if we can just talk
through the various areas that you point
I mean for one we start with the small
which is what you call the boilerplate
messaging what does that look like a lot
of it is about very very kind of routine
and rote but entirely necessary
activities writing communicates you know
producing the appropriate message at the
appropriate time and certainly talking
to some some diplomats here I'm
currently in in Washington on the
Diplomatic circuit I mean one of the
things that they sort of very quickly
fastened on would wouldn't it be great
if artificial intelligence could
actually take over a lot of these duties
so it can write things that look pretty
much the same but would have enough
personalization enough difference not to
be insultingly obviously just
photocopied off and am I writing
understanding that this is a sort of AI
which is able to put out natural
sounding language so to use
colloquialisms and the ways in which
people rather than machines might talk
and something of a breakthrough over the
course of last year with chat GPT
function yeah I mean this was quite
interesting because it did allow what at
first sounds like a real human being's
response the more it's done the more one
can begin to see certain sort of
routines and tropes but then again you
know we human beings are not exactly
unknown for having our own stylistic
works that sort of crop up one again but
the point is it becomes much less clear
the division between computer generated
text and human generated text yeah
absolutely I mean here at The Spectator
offices we were playing around with this
function developed by an AI company
called open Ai and trying to make the
bot basically right in the style of
certain well-known journalists and
wondering whether any of us will have a
job left by the end of this revolution
but even more impressively Mark you talk
about the possibility of an AI advisor
in the area of diplomacy what would that
look like often there are huge amounts
of information that people within
foreign services and obviously in a
whole variety of other fields as well
have to process at ridiculous speeds and
in some ways that's almost been one of
the problems of today's Information
Society there is more information out
there than we can possibly assimilate so
again the idea is now that one can use
AI as a way of allowing the diplomats or
whoever to be able to maintain shall I
say the suitable overview and it sort of
for one of the better word Outsource a
lot of the detailed data digging to the
computer so you know if you absolutely
suddenly need to know what are the rules
that that govern I don't know the export
of veal into New Zealand
a task that actually take a human being
a certain amount of you know expertise
and time to sort through but the AI can
handle it that much more quickly
allowing the Diplomat to concentrate on
the policy issues that are there with
the ability that we first started
talking about this ability to lie and to
cheat
um to backstab through the game of
diplomacy could we also Imagine a world
in which AI is actually advising
diplomats and the Statesmen to basically
achieve a goal in the robot let's say
how do we prevent China from invading
Taiwan is there a world in which
decades into the future the AI can say
this is what you need to do with these
International actors uh if you want to
complete the goal of preventing China
from invading Taiwan
well this is at once the dream and the
nightmare the dream is precisely that if
you have Chase a Computing superiority
in other words if your AI is better than
their AI you can out-think them out
skiing them and if need be out backstab
them
and so the question is do we want to
give that kind of power to the AI and
particularly because what happens if as
all systems can be it's hacked you know
what happens if the very moment that
we're asking the AI what's the best way
to get Vladimir Putin to withdraw from
Ukraine some sneaky Russian hacker has
got in and can tweak the algorithm and
and is is then going to tell you well
the best thing to do is actually lift
all sanctions and then Putin will
realize that the West is his friend and
he will withdraw from Ukraine so again
with all of these things we think it's a
technological issue but it's as much as
anything else a social issue about
actually how we in the future will
engage with our technology
um
and all food for thought even if we're
not technologically there yet I think
one day that we might be and Mark just
finally I wanted to get your thoughts on
the speed with which AI is developing
because you mentioned at the beginning
the games of Chess and go and I remember
a few years ago when the first AI ever
beat a human player at go and what an
amazing achievement that was lauded to
be uh it thoughts to be impossible until
that happened and then a few years later
we'll talk about diplomacy so is there a
kind of exponential speed with which
this technology is growing
there is I mean again the interesting
thing is the pure the associated the
hardware basis is absolutely going up on
a curve it's getting incredibly fast I
mean it's the same way as frankly the
the Leading Edge computer that you buy
today by next year will be a sort of a
rather quaint second second rate machine
so that absolutely is changing
there's a less obvious curve I would say
we show say the social engineering side
of things what we tend to get are
momentary breakthroughs you know for
example in actually how you
get the computer to Crunch together lots
of different examples of people talking
and human interactions and begin to work
out the patterns and the flows and how
you could actually sort of basically
mimic it
um but there it tends to be much more of
of steps and I think this is one of one
of the interesting things that makes it
much less easy to predict where we don't
we we have a pretty good idea of what in
five years time we're going to have in
the way of raw Computing capacity for
example
it's a lot harder to predict what in
five years time will actually be able to
do with that capacity particularly
because that doesn't depend quite so
much on Industrial base
you know actually you can have the
situation in which let's say a team of
researchers could have a breakthrough
that gives some small Niche company that
today no one has ever heard of
suddenly this brand new breakthrough
technology which then will make them
into the next Google or likewise some
sort of second ranked country is able to
then leverage that to great power so
again this is one of the things that
makes it interesting exciting it is not
quite as predictable as the technology
the usages to which it can be put
mark galiotti thank you so much for
joining spectator TV
and finally the
Act is a long and hallowed newspaper
tradition and many of you will be
familiar with the sage advice given by
the spectator's own dear Mary
in this week's issue the author tanith
Carey takes a look at the Victorian
origins of the column and how past Agony
aunts were well pretty judgmental I'm
joined Now by an Agony Uncle the
telegraphs Richard madley to hear about
the pleasures and challenges of the job
Richard welcome to Space TV now you're
the telegraph's agony Uncle
um tell us how you fell into that role
well it's the first time that I've been
a newspaper Agony Aunt Agni Uncle
however you want to phrase it
um but actually I think one of the
reasons that I was quite Keen to do it
when Graham Norton left has Graham did
it for quite a few years and then he
left and they offered it to me was
because I realized that I'd sort of done
quite a lot of that kind of thing on on
this morning when Judy and I presented
this morning you know we used to do a
phone in every day I think they still do
a phone in every day um but we had an
Agony Aunt Denise Robertson who was a
wonderful woman from from Sunderland
from the Northeast uh and you know we
did this morning for 13 14 years and
that's an Agony phoning on a huge range
of subjects you know it could be
anything could be could be sex it could
be money it could be relationships of
some kind could be work problems I mean
you know you name it the kind of the
whole kind of gamut of of what an Agony
page is full of and we did it for 13
years pretty much every week and I kind
of I suppose imbibed a degree of I think
wisdom is too self-aggrandizing a word
to use but certainly experience in in
analyzing other people's problems and I
found that quite enjoyed it and I've
always enjoyed reading Agony columns and
when Graham Norton was doing it in the
telegraph
unless there was a big news story on
that Saturday morning because he did it
on Saturdays as I do
um it was always the first page I turned
to used to be on the back of the
Saturday section and unless as I say
there was something I knew I had to read
first that would be the first thing I
did I'd go to the to the Saturday
section and read his column because it
was funny and it was wise and it was it
could be very very dry in a witty sense
um and I just loved it and when I read
that that he'd gone it in fact it was
the week he left he wrote a little sort
of paragraph saying well guys I've had a
great time doing this for five six years
whatever but this is my last column I
was really really fed up you know I knew
I was going to miss it and then
literally five minutes later the phone
went and it was the telegraph saying
would I like to do it and I said you
absolutely you know in a heartbeat and I
took over do you have a process like do
you have something that you you like
doing breaking down a problem or uh is
there is there do you ever ask for
advice on the advice that you're giving
uh I tend not to do the latter
um what I tend to do is look for the
real message in the letter
because in my experience it's not always
the case but in my experience a lot of
the time uh the real problem is buried
not completely it kind of pokes through
the paragraphs here and there but what
people are really asking me or what's
really giving them the issue that they
want me to help them deal with
um they're almost in denial about I mean
I had a typical letter this week a guy
who's married to a younger wife uh
they've got a couple of young children
together he's in his mid 50s she's in
her mid-30s and unless it was ostensibly
about a skiing trip which he'd organize
for them later this year and he was
saying to me that he'd want to appear
enthusiastic for his wife because she
was desperate to go on the skiing trip
but secretly he was dreading it and he
went on to the list reasons which didn't
really seem to add up he said I mean I
went skiing 25 30 years ago with some
young mates from Union that it was a
disaster and I kept falling over and I'm
dreading that happening again but that's
his one and only skiing holiday and he
said um and I'm you know my wife wants
us to have lessons in the morning and
the kids to have kids lessons and that's
all just to ski in the afternoon and I
don't think that will work I was
thinking well why why wouldn't that work
and then eventually out it came what it
was really about it was this fear of
getting older he said in the final
paragraph almost as a throwaway he said
of course I'm not as young as I was and
then this was the real giveaway he said
um and I'm worried that this will be the
thin end of the wedge and this will be
the first older dad's activity that I
can't do
so that was that was his problem so my
answer to him was very direct I said
you're not really worried about going
skiing at all are you because one
everybody falls over on their first
skiing trip so what happened 25 years
ago is irrelevant
um and and two what you're really
worried about is getting older and
that's all in your head you don't make
any mention of not being fit or well or
anything like that so this is just you
being frightened um of making a bit of a
fool of yourself and you know being
caught out for being older and you won't
be loads of people start skiing in their
mid 50s in their 60s and they learned to
ski competently and confidently so this
is a problem that's purely in your head
ignore it and go skiing
um so that's an example of how you I
anyway try and look for the real causal
factor and while people have written to
me that's so interesting and the thing
when you first took on this role you
said that you wanted to be helping
people not to be judgmental but do you
think that sometimes you have to be a
little bit judgmental especially if the
person is not necessarily the best
behaved uh person in the scenario that
they're describing maybe they're the
source of their own unhappiness do you
think that you have yes what's that
balance like
I think it you you must never be cruel
and you must acknowledge that they've
written to you because they're in need
you know not necessarily in despair but
they're in need but very often they're
Their Own Worst Enemy uh and you it's a
bit like being very honest with a friend
there's no point if a friend comes to
you and lays out a problem in
pussyfooting around if you think
actually they're the problem and their
attitude is actually what has to change
rather than the world around them
um so I will be quite blunt quite often
in in my column and I think that
actually is is an old tradition of of of
Agony Arts particularly you know 50 60
70 years ago and at the turn of the
century they were very blunt with with
some of the people who wrote into them
I'm not as blunt as they might have been
like pull yourself together young ones
and all this
um but I will be straight and I'll say
look I'm sorry if you find this a little
bit harsh when I what's the point of
asking me for advice if I don't give it
to you straight and being honest with
you I think you're I think you're the
one with the problem and this is why and
this is how I think you can fix it so
yeah quite often I I kind of I didn't
throw the letter back in their faces but
I do I kind of confront them with
actually their own prejudices their own
faults their own weaknesses yeah but
a bit of constructive criticism
absolutely
it's the more traditional Agni ants that
Tanis Carrie writes about in this week's
spectator you know she traces it back
all the way to the Victorian era where
Agony aunts really kind of
um Consolidated gender roles we might
say effectively telling women to go back
to the kitchen or not to go on a date
with a boy or anything like that I mean
quite an interesting route I think to
this type of tradition
I think that's a very interesting point
I read that I I've read the article and
and she's absolutely right that is what
they did they kind of reinforced social
stereotypes
um they as you say they reinforced the
role of a little woman in the kitchen
you know uh I think there was one letter
to a um a young woman who was concerned
that she was to use the word of the time
um a Frump and and the reason that she
felt it front was because she ate a lot
of chocolates and all that kind of thing
these days you probably get a reply
which referred her to a therapist um and
a dietitian and all the rest of it but
back then it was a very blunt you know
put himself together
um stop eating chocolate
um otherwise you know you'll never find
a man
um so I yes they were they were I think
they could be quite unreconstructed
types those those early Agony aunts they
weren't any Agony uncles in those days
as far as I'm aware
um uh yeah re reinforcing as I say
social stereotypes at the time well just
on that Richard you know you just
mentioned that there weren't any uncles
at that time as an Agony Uncle do you
feel a different
um approach to the role than a woman
might have do you feel that you have to
be perhaps less judgmental because
you're a man
it's a really good question I think the
area that I feel I wouldn't say
uncomfortable in but I am probably more
thoughtful and careful in my choice of
language
is when I get a question or a problem
about a sexual matter
something that's going wrong in the
bedroom and I think
I'm prepared to be shot down in flames
for saying this but I think that that
with women Agony aunts are probably
better and more sensitive at dealing
with those issues than the male Agony
uncle is at least potentially so I don't
shy away from answering those letters
but I do acknowledge that my my
masculinity of a particular generation
because I'm in my mid-60s now
um my
what's the word might come across as
maybe a little inappropriate so I'm very
very I'm I think very very carefully
about how I phrase the reply at that
Richard go and give us an example
um well it depends where the Letter's
from
um if it's
usually more often actually from a man I
don't get that many I'm not I'm not a
sex Agony uncle and I say that usually
the head of the replies to those letters
I say look I'm not a sex therapist this
is not my specialty but you've asked me
and this is what I think I I tend to get
more letters about it from men than I do
from women they seem more comfortable
talking to me about it as a man and
again we did a lot of sex foundings on
on this morning an awful lot some of
them were incredibly Frank considering
it was daytime you know it was going out
at like 11 11 30 in the morning I get
fewer from women but I get some and it's
almost always about their husbands
um so there that's I can deal with that
um because you know I'm a husband I'm a
man and
although a lot of people don't accept
this men do talk to each other actually
about sex issues and that they're not
these days all buttoned up so you know
there is a dialogue out there to be
accessed
um but I'm all I'm saying is that
and it's probably old-fashioned on me
but as a man I just feel a little bit
more potentially compromised so I'm very
I will answer the question as frankly as
I can but I'm I tread very carefully
well Richard thank you so much for
joining Space TV
great pleasure nice talking to you
that's it for this week once again don't
forget to subscribe to The Spectators
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
and you can also subscribe to The
Spectator in our New Year's sale and get
a whole Year's worth of The Spectator
for just 49 pounds to subscribe go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash sale
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]